de mon fils tu fais quoi ta jalousie et
aujourd'hui on est sur fahrenheit
atelier d'un jeu d'horreur qui est en
fait un point'n click voilà donc on se
bat là on se balade pas avec les touches
du clavier etc mais uniquement avec la
souris câble trop petit de merde ce
parti new game alors ça c'est une petite
annonce donc une pizzeria cherche un
garde de nuit
voilà donc je suppose qu'on a condé le
garde de nuit un et qu'on n'est pas le
mec qui fait des claquettes sur la scène
pour faire rigoler les enfants
n'auraient pu être marrant
le téléphone sonne tlf comment je vais
dégager d'accord ok non c'est sérieux je
suis censé traduire ce que c'est à midi
au téléphone
donc en fait on est un garde de nuit
dans une pizzeria qu'en fait ces trois
personnages du jour sont très mignons
très sympathique mais la nuit il ya un
problème
ce qui fait que ils se déplacent
librement et c'est en gros ils me
veulent du mal
voilà moi je suis chargé de la sécurité
dans cet endroit le pire job de la
planète donc c'est eux les trois en
question je suppose c'est ça vous pouvez
me répondre non eh ben c'est parfait ok
le salaire de jouer uniquement comme ça
en gros j'ai accès à plein de caméras un
peu partout en bas il ya une barre de
pouvoir restant et d'utilisation je peux
si je ferme la porte
ok d'accord donc ça ça baisse le power
restant très bien et ben c'est génial et
si je reste à tête là dedans c'est moi
ça me va très bien pour le moment ils
sont pas trop pas trop animer la nuit
est simple et beaucoup déjà j'ai du mal
à comprendre pourquoi des gens viennent
voir trois robots comme sabella glauque
je vois dans une pizzeria je fermais la
pizzeria en question je porte plainte
immédiatement et le truc marrant c'est
qu'en fait - il bon ok ce qui se passe
ça c'est moins marrant par exemple un
geste envers nac est parti mon gars à
illéla regarder le à ces affreuses aux
cryptes comme jeu en fait tu attends tu
as tort contre coupe la tête quoi
finalement toi ta petite cabine là-haut
[ __ ] il est où
ok il est là c'est c'est lui 1 il est là
ça c'est bien lui là avec ses deux
petites oreilles façon crêpes whaou et
années on entend chanter non mais en
fait je pense qu'il a cru que c'était le
jour donc il fait comme s'il se donne en
spectacle pour les enfants mais enfin
c'est un bug de robots quoi hein ah oui
dites moi cui bordel rassurez-moi rester
là tous les deux un vous aux [ __ ] non
non non non il n'en reste plus qu'un ol
et frost regarder le jeu tchèque
absolument les couloirs on voit rien
dans ces [ __ ] de couloir quoi bien
oui
fermeture des portes à la voyez là par
exemple j'utilise énormément de pouvoir
que les portes sont fermées mais ça me
plaît beaucoup aux ils étaient là ont
regardé le hilal est dans le couloir
juste à côté tu n'auras jamais je ce
bruit que repousse créatures de l'ombre
il doit qui fait lui un bruit comme ça
il fait ouais abri robotique comme moi
ou saloperie qu'est ce qui l'attend est
donc j'appelle peut-être voilà en fait
il rêve d'être un enfant normal mais non
c'est un robot au regard des lives et
nous séduire ça c'est un regard
séducteur mais je sais reconnaître un
séducteur lui les séducteurs il nous
veux je peux plus je peux plus rien
faire j'ai perdu on verra ce qu'ils
meurent mais c'est évident lucas pas
trop fort de son eau
on passe de 5 heures du matin à six
heures du matin
amusez vous et amusez vous donc moi je
le fais décapiter la gueule dans mon
bureau
ok seconde nuit à toi on a géré la
première nuit quand même un diplôme
relève diplôme
regardez mais attendez c'est pas
possible quoi tient la caméra il fait ça
c'est pas du tout normal de faire des
choses pareilles
si je met en lumière sa les frais j'ai
envie de savoir est-ce que ça les ferait
narry son bail state car au contraire il
se donne encore plus un show à thème ça
les lumières et les paillettes amérique
en plat il est là il est dans le hall
ouest quoi ah [ __ ] le deuxième est
parti à l'année le riad et le dans
l'ombre là il croit qu'il est caché un
jd les yeux de daigle 1 1 voilà c'est
mon imitation de l'aigle il ya des vieux
bruit et des vieux bruit dégueulasse
comme cyrielle apporte avec ses clefs de
voiture
l'attaquant de merde h obligé d'ouvrir
au saté libyen continue de chanter je ne
reçois pas ça me fait plaisir a donc
donc lui les à la cantine lui fait son
show lui il est plus à la cantine plus
tard mais en changement de caméra il a
fait je vais décédé je vais décédé
[ __ ] je les décès des noms mais lui
c'est comme suit qu'est la pire tête des
3g pas si vous êtes jumeaux ou quoi mais
en tout cas il ya une grosse injustice
dans bande de votre maman s'acheter à me
dire oui il est en stand by depuis
vingt-huit minutes je pas ce qui lui
arrive tel qu'il fonctionne en bluetooth
et que le thème tout s'est cassé je ne
sais pas lui l'a encore à faire son show
c'est un soir et voilà il est là il
s'est dit bon ce soir c'est pour moi les
payet les que 4 heures du matin il nous
reste 2 % de battre accurso
c'est pour ce qui nous permettra de
survivre
ah ah non supplée en tout cas pas celui
qu en tête de poule à ah ouais ouais
ouais ça me fait un show j'avais
apprécié tout spectacle je vais te
donner une pièce est c'est parti
en fait faut vraiment que j'utilise ça
uniquement quand c'est vraiment vraiment
nécessaire là les trois ils sont là je
m'en fous j'attends beaucoup le gameplay
un peu moins palpitant même plutôt
chiant peut le dire mais je dois
vraiment économiser la batterie voilà y
en a déjà qui s'est barré en courant il
est où il est où il vous faut que je
trouve une fois rien mais je m'en fous
mais au fait pourquoi j'utilise pas la
can que pour regarder les couloirs qui
sont à côté de moi je m'en fous qu'ils
soient loin en soit on s'en fout voilà
là par exemple on s'en fout moins quand
il est là comme ça s'il est parti à
arrêter vous arrête tu vas finir par
maman il reste cinq heures à tenir à la
maison mais c'est intenable ce rythme
quoi bon le chef de la pizza degrés
investir dans une centrale ça c'est un
manchon que j'ai jamais joué un jeu
dehors aussi oppressant lyonnais font
plus peur que ça mais cela il est
oppressante et là qu'est ce que je fais
il ya dix huit 18 caméras un amour ce
qui fait de la basse un outil qui se
prend pour vanessa paradis à chaque fois
mais qu'est que fais-je bon il y en a
qu'un qui est parti bah il est là pour
lui et pas très intelligent voilà il
pense qu'il est caché il en plein milieu
devant il ya non aux aînés intelligent
il a coupé la caméra il est dégueu
celui-là ben en fait je suis sûr qu'il
fait cette tête pour pour justement que
je reste sur cette caméra pour bien
regarder pendant que ses deux copains
cours vers moi comme ça aurait décapité
j'ai vu clair en tête dans ton jeu avant
ta stratégie aussi j'ai vu clair un tu
veux ma tirez-vous en tête sexy pour que
les autres viennent non non vous n'aurez
plus les gars arrête arrête en bas tu as
regardé le entre de rideau il faire son
petit show lui aussi lui les programmes
g ok donc l'elite servent à ça il est
encore là coucou coucou je suis grillé à
les partis c'est bon teint les mecs mais
tata pire job d'été de la planète
entière et pro fusil à pompe pour aller
au boulot je sais pas juste la sphère
son regard de pervers la hoya la pizza
mène jusqu'au gardien de nuit et je ne
propose aucune pizzas gratuites ou
payantes par contre je viens vous posez
des pizzas contre ma vie saine et sauve
il va arriver là
wallace de chars je savais j'ai fait des
enquêtes plus profonde que ça mon gars
l'exemple turc qui avait volé ma
dernière paire de chaussettes un ya rien
de plus chiant on est d'accord
ayano de l'autre côté [ __ ] home et
surtout cela il ya la lui ai juste à
côté de nous qu'est ce qu'ils veulent
après ça faisait trois heures qui a été
debout dans le couloir attendre comme ça
d'un coup je sais pas s il se passe un
truc dans son cerveau ici je courais
mais bien sûr c'est pas normal il ya un
problème il ya une heure du matin et je
sens déjà quelques sueurs sur mon front
il va venir lui va venir nous voir il va
passer à l'action
là il se dit bon est ce que je veux
c'est dur en vrai ou pas je les entends
marché en plus l'accueil jeunes de
robots là soyez discret un peu investi
dans des jambes en polystyrène
j'espère que tu n'as pas nous refaire
une crise où ils courent d'un coup elle
est trois heures trois heures trois
heures à aller c'est ce qu'on appelle se
prendre un stop
non mais stop battant déjà je comprends
pas pourquoi le mec et du travail et une
nuits qui l'a vu que ces robots voulait
le tuer pourquoi il est revenu la
deuxième nuit tu as dans ton lit au côté
gauche
c'est un gauche pourquoi chaque fois je
ferme celle de droite n'y a rien c'est
le droit ya peut-être une princesse qui
veut venir m'aider on sait pas princesse
et tu demont côté droit
je t'ai claire j'éclaire ta beauté je
vais rester tourner vers cette porte là
ok c'est toujours à 7 portails qui se
passe des choses à rassurer moi s'il
vous plaît c'est horrible j'aimerais
tellement que toi qui as rcd autre
puisse me faire
oui lucas ne t'inquiète pas et je ferai
merci valentin ou ou geoffrey j'en sais
rien merci merci de m'aider de me
rassurer
1 puis ensuite on irait chez pas à
prendre le goûter ensemble devant les
totally spies
mais là du coup non y'a rien de tout ça
quand vous verrez ça je serais déjà mort
mort de peur pétain en position foetale
devant martin matin pas lui qui court si
c'est lui qui court à chaque fois un
petit [ __ ] de merde
hop là c'est ce qu'on appelle un non non
je ne pas sortir avec toi vas t'en nous
appelle la police c'est bien on tient on
tient martin matin c'est pour nous
j'aimerais qu'un psychologue mme assiste
actuellement tu es psychologue tu vas
t'on diplôme de psychologue
alors viens me voir et aide moi à battre
ces [ __ ] ndour ce psychopathe qui
font rire les enfants mais qui me font
moins rires je savais ben oui bah stop
aux mêmes et arrêtent quoi j'appelle la
police
bon très bien je sais pas de téléphone
mais je l'appellerai après il est
cinquième
ok on s'enferme barricades barricades
prend mais j'ai panda avec nous et on
prie on a cette batterie pour tenir fils
de chien le réflexe immédiat soit plus
être mon frère mon père robert ou
n'importe quel jour édifice de chiens
voilà c'est bon oh [ __ ]
non c'est bon allez on a tenu on
appelait on a même s'il vous plaît cette
tête quoi je suis là s'y écoule ses jets
aguas qui m'a dit c'est trop il aime
dire bon cette nuit tu vas mourir
prépare toi à manger un bon burger mais
tes pieds dans une bassine d'eau chaude
banon voilà moi je vais mourir en
n'ayant absolument rien fait de tout ça
taylor il appelle sa crise de
schizophrénie puisque j'ai fermé la
porte avant en fait du coup on s'est dit
qu'il allait prendre la porte qu'il
allait avoir une bosse sur le front et
que les enfants allaient se moquer de
lui il a dit bon finalement je vais
laisser comme ça bon oh vous savez qui
s'était c'était monsieur dog fights
voilà je vous le remet monsieur fils de
chien la prochaine fois il sera là mais
comme ça avant de prendre une photo avec
moi en font en train de me chier dessus
pas fermé la porte
voilà dans le jeu et à beugin peut plus
rien faire je crois que le je pense que
je suis mort alors que pas du tout il ya
eu le screamer mais j'ai dû je suis pas
à mettre la caméra ou l'enlever pile au
bon moment ce qui fait que je suis pas
mort mais par contre je peux plus rien
faire
mais le temps on continue d'avancer je
vais sûrement passer la troisième but
comme ça voilà voilà
ou alors ya peut-être un robot qui est
derrière moi et qui me tient les bras
comme ça s'il expliquait pourquoi je
peux rien faire ou alors il ya peut-être
s'en fout mais où sont donc les robots
tueurs dans un bug
à 0% est ce que c'est la victoire
attends une pièce est une pièce est une
pièce elle bouge pas bougez pas tiens
voilà voyez ici vous et lui donner une
pièce est pour qu'il me laisse en vie
[ __ ] j'en étais sûr aller pour toi non
pas toi clavier alors 5e nuit y en a
déjà qui fait son petit spectacle entre
les deux un kiff étiez chez les
chirurgiens on peut dire c'est surgir de
ces robots et inquiets se prend encore
prenait sa part a dit c'est parfait oui
dogfights man je peux sentir ton selphy
de crise je suis en train de guérir
voilà mes poils sont en pleine mutinerie
à ils se sont tous soulevé bon on voit
les gens solides pour fans l'attendent
freddy g face aux hors applus ces cas
n'hésitez pas aimer l'hebdo ça fera un
grand plaisir honnêtement c'est un jeu
vraiment hyper aux pressions étant donné
que tu peux rien faire tu vois juste et
vont se rapprocher petit à petit et tu
peux pas vraiment concrètement le cuir
que juste fermer des portes voilà dire
non je ne pas regarder que toi ça suffit
sincèrement je pensais pas qu'un jeu
avec un gameplay comme ça arrive rien
autant me mettre la pression à ne vous
l'avez vu c'était la mutinerie des poils
de bras donc bon comme d'habitude on se
retrouve très vite dans une nouvelle
vidéo tient tout le monde et ça voilà
c'était le front édition
[Musique]